question is
what advice would you give an
intermediate life stage
36 year old who wants to career
pivot from medical technology and
research to computer science
so first by computer science i think you
mean
the broad field that includes software
engineering machine learning
robotics just computing in general maybe
with less emphasis on the mathematical
side like theoretical computer science
i think the best advice on this that i
could give is
find a simple project to get excited
about
and allow yourself to get really excited
by it
have fun fall in love with it
be proud of the thing you create and i
should say there's a big emphasis on the
simple
don't go super ambitious i believe that
most people if they allow themselves can
derive a huge amount of joy for creating
some simple little things
even if it's following a tutorial if you
just allow yourself to experience the
joy of creation
it's there for you that's that's one of
the magical things about computer
science
is it allows you to create things
that are almost like entities on their
own that's what programs are
so i i think a career in computer
science starts first
with allowing yourself to be passionate
and getting that stoking that flame
and allowing it to build so it's not
about any other practical like which job
do i get what thing i work on is just
really
giving yourself over to the simple
passion
of creating stuff i think there's just a
quick set of steps
that i think i followed early on
that i would also recommend you at least
consider following is
first is basic software engineering so
finding maybe python or javascript like
super popular
accessible programming language and
build just like a hello world program
or something just a little bit more
complicated but not much more
beyond that is using that newly acquired
set of tools of programming build
something that automates something you
do on the computer
maybe another way to phrase that is just
like scripts that are
helping you in your interaction with the
computer so maybe
finding different files in your computer
that you try to look for
often or reorganizing things
in an automated way like folder
structures or maybe renaming files
like i have a script that finds all the
files that have
spaces in the file name and it renames
them
after confirmation to underscores all
those kinds of things
there's a bunch of little helpless
scripts i have all over the place and
those are just really joyful because you
get to use them every day
and it's something that you've created
that made your life a little bit easier
i for me at least that's a source of joy
that helps feed that like love of
programming
of just being a part of the computing of
the computer science world
and i've been doing that really my whole
life it started with
c and c plus plus but now it's a lot of
other languages
primarily python and yes javascript
next is a branching into two separate
little worlds in computer science
of uh algorithms and then
like data science i think both are
full of beautiful things to fall in love
with
the thing you can really enjoy with
algorithms is learning how to build
more and more efficient algorithms on
the data side
is learning how to process different
data sets how to
clean them up how to reorganize them and
do different kind of
statistics on them processing on them so
we're not even talking about machine
learning yet it's just
being able to visualize those datasets
all those kinds of stuff just working
with data
and now we're starting to talk about
career
because there's a lot of jobs that have
to do with
the use of computing techniques to
process
visualize and interpret aggregate
analyze data
so that's i guess you would call that
field
data science so that's a really cool
career trajectory and there's so many
cool things to get into
with i think a very reasonable small
learning curve that you can
really if you push yourself do within
weeks
maybe months not years and once you
become comfortable with the data science
world
you can start building on on top of that
quite naturally
doing some boilerplate machine learning
supervised learning projects and then
building
out into more specific more useful more
novel cutting edge applications of
machine learning
reinforcement learning that whole world
maybe even taking that into physical
systems of actually building robots
and i should backtrack it it sounds like
i'm building towards something super
complicated but it's not all these can
be really small projects
even robotics projects you can build a
little robot
that uh does some basic tasks maybe does
some basic computer vision
and it's a nice way to learn on the
robotics side and better systems
programming so it's just getting more
comfortable with hardware and seeing
like if that's something you're
interested in
or on the data science side where you're
sticking much more to the software
both of those you now start to figure
out what is the
exciting career possibility i think two
things even i would even see them as
skills are important here
passion and google i see
passion as a skill because it's allowing
yourself to be excited
it's finding things you could be excited
about and allow yourself to be excited
and seeing that as an actually essential
part of progress
is allowing yourself to be excited and
the reason i mentioned google is because
i find that in a lot of fields but
especially in computer science with
software engineering and machine
learning
there's so many amazing resources out
there that the key
skill actually ends up being is how good
are you at discovering
the exact page and
resources that is allowing you to take
the next step in your journey of
exploration of learning
and that's fundamentally a skill of how
do i google
the right thing what pages do i click on
and all those kinds of things i think it
sounds almost kind of ridiculous
to say that that's a skill but that is
one of the most essential
skills of the modern day
student lifelong student is how to
google
so yeah passion and google
allow yourself to fall in love with the
project and uh
keep taking the next step the next step
next up with the help
of a good search engine and a bit of
curiosity
you